la provincia del sur de Ucrania tiene al
menos el 50% de su territorio o más en
control de las fuerzas ocupantes y allí
hay una gran línea de batalla que divide
tanto la parte en control de las fuerzas
rusas como las que están en control de
las fuerzas ucranianas Allí se planea o
se piensa que va a comenzar esta
contraofensiva de la que tanto se ha
hablado en los últimos días y que no ha
comenzado según algunos analistas es
debido a las condiciones climáticas si
bien ha salido el sol en los últimos
días y ya algunas de esas vías están
secas se prevén lluvias para los
próximos días y así que todo el mundo
está a la espera de cuándo son las
condiciones para comenzar en sus
movimientos sin embargo tanto de la
ucraniano como el ruso empiezan a
prepararse esta semana las autoridades
ocupantes del lado del ruso de la
provincia de saporilla han ordenado la
evacuación parcial de
como en arjodar donde se encuentra la
planta nuclear y otras 18 poblaciones
cerca a esta línea de frente quien está
el trian de allí serían especialmente
niños mujeres y personas mayores sin
embargo la mayor atención ha estado en
el donde está esta planta nuclear porque
la organización internacional de energía
atómica ha dicho que le preocupa mucho
su situación especialmente porque han
comenzado y se han incrementado los
ataques en los últimos días sin embargo
la agencia rosatón la agencia rusa de
energía atómica ha dicho que no hay nada
de que preocuparse que los hombres y las
personas que trabajan allí en esta
planta nuclear no están siendo evacuados
y que todo está bajo control pero sí se
conoce que por ejemplo la población de
nikopol al frente de narrada en control
de las fuerzas ucranianas ha sido
atacadas sistemáticamente incluido esta
mañana donde murió una mujer mayor y
tres quedaron heridos Y estos ataques
continúan sistemáticamente a de esta
línea de frente donde las autoridades
ucranianas aseguran que los ataques
rusos se han incrementado